he of Ramsey solutions Chris and
Jennifer are with us hey guys how are
you hey
welcome welcome good to have you so
where are you guys from from Louisville
Kentucky oh that's not too bad at
reachable and but I appreciate you
coming down to do your debt-free scream
in person right how much debt of y'all
paid off 114 thousand dollars I love it
and how long did that take you
it took us 19 months very cool making
what kind of money during that time
average during the time was 150 okay
what'd you guys do for a living I'm a
commercial real estate underwriter and
I'm a nurse practitioner at a local
Children's Hospital Oh fun good very
cool so what kind of debt was the
hundred and fourteen thousand it was our
mortgage oh you pay off your house we
did yeah
your weird weird no debt weird
I love it you're so young and you don't
have a mortgage it's great how much is
this house worth 140 maybe the house I
think was part of my stupid tax as much
as a house could be I bought the house
to impress a woman it worked because
it's she's standing next to me okay but
I rushed into it I overpaid so anybody
listening out there we want to say go
through your LPS so that they can get
some good advice and make a a better
purchase thing they did but you're still
you got a nice home it's paid for you
got the woman everything's good
absolutely very cool so how long have
y'all been married four years okay so
what happened 19 months ago tell me the
story so he came to me with this idea of
paying off the the house and of course I
wanted things and I didn't really I
wasn't on the the same wave link and he
kind of put it in a chart where he
showed me what interest would be over 25
years and I didn't like it so we just
kind of decided let's do this I'm
definitely the nerd pretty good salesman
there nerd I built the name schedule
yeah lay it out there and go look how
hooky this is and she went yeah that's
sucky yeah let's do this
the the catalyst was Jennifer started
her job when we first got married we
were living together just on my income
I said I've got this crazy idea we've
lived on my salary for for two years now
let's pretend that this degree that
you've worked so hard for that the
income we don't even see it so she'd get
paid on Friday I could go straight down
to the bank make the payment back out to
the wild Wow very cool so it was
straight up your salary then that did
this yes yeah you did win when you got
this woman so she paid off the house and
let you come along that's pretty cool
story and I'm sticking to it
it's fun y'all very well done very well
done well that's neat so he hands you
the spreadsheet that sees all the
numbers on it and how quickly did they
have to sit in for two days two weeks 20
minutes
no is instant instant you just want that
turns your stomach Your Honor we're not
doing that you're right we can put off
we can live like no one else and then
later we can live like no one else pay a
price to win very cool so what was the
hardest part of the nineteen months for
you all I think for me it was tithing
off to salaries but living off one oh
that was that was pretty difficult but
through it all you know God God he
constantly sought us through it and he
provided and we got through yeah very
cool yeah it's interesting how that
always happens yeah yeah I never hear
anybody says I start tithing oh my life
fell apart you know I never hear that it
just never comes up that way maybe it
happens and I just won't tell about it
but I never hear that so Wow
well congratulations you guys very cool
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is the key for me is
just being on the same page you're
working together you have to agree what
you're going to do with your money and
the budget when we first got started
probably the first eight months of
paying off the debt
we weren't really on a budget we were
just kind of saying okay we know you
make this much money we're gonna ship
that out and we had a savings account
over on the side and at the end of every
month we kept having to go into the
savings account
let me out to cover you know groceries
and gas
and stuff that we missed stuff that we
missed yeah so we got on a budget and we
just stuck to it the last several months
and now we're using the every dollar app
which is fantastic I love it thank you
I still haven't given up my spreadsheets
that I built I'm working with them side
by side there's always a period of time
to surrender and yes but every dollar is
wonderful and that's really helped to go
to the grocery store and as you're
walking out putting the groceries in the
car you can punch it in and it
automatically updates and you know
exactly where you are all the time oh
that's fun it does keep it doesn't make
it budgeting a whole lot easier yeah how
we did it with the yellow pad all these
years or a spreadsheet all these years
was beyond me but we did it so it's very
cool well congratulations you too
I'm very very very well done absolutely
love it how old are you I'm 31 and I we
paid off the debt just before I turn 30
ah and you have a paid-for house yes I
mean how many people made fun of y'all
while you were doing this you know we
really didn't have a lot of people
making fun of us there's nothing really
change you just lived on your salary
right yeah yeah we just kind of kept
going the way we were and we had a lot
of support and encouragement from our
families and they all dancing with you
they are and I I did want to say I can
remember from the time I was really
little that my dad telling me some
advice that his father-in-law my
grandfather had given him dad would
always say that my grandfather told him
son if you pay your house off first you
can have anything you want in life yeah
and that's really stuck with me
especially through the last two years as
we've been doing this and now you're 30
and you did it yes I mean he's smiling
yes he you know he's smiling that's
awesome well congratulations you two
Chris and Jennifer Louisville Kentucky a
hundred and fourteen thousand dollars
paid off that's her house and everything
right before he turned 30 I love it 19
months it took I'm making a hundred a
half count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one Gouri god
we're debt-free
well done
I love it I love it I love it